welcome to this video playing drain you
sooner back Hansen from from Sweden
let's see I don't know what he plays
laughs maybe yep let's see what he's got
in store against my current pet line
with queen bee three probably Bishop g4
yeah that's the main choice nowadays
let's see if he knows this new line with
e5 or if you place the traditional
capture and e5 and it's not like the old
line is is is bad by any means it just
seems that you five is a new interesting
alternative can show you the point
afterwards ok staking taking his time
here
okay yeah it comes up with it anyway um
yeah going with this this very very
solid choice it does not promise white
very much but I'm not a big fan of the
alternatives like de 5 and so on we
should be six now and now we get them
get a fairly a normal-looking position
is it there should be three or more
castles hmm not completely sure
castles I think Bishop f4 or yeah I
guess so Bishop f4 51 rock d1 first
bishop 26 yeah bishop g6 somehow the
move h5 comes two comes to mind well I
cannot really believe in that rook d 1
plus looks very normal yeah look at the
one Queen B 6 Queen a4 to see to a snide
a for threatening just Queenie 7 seems
okay and what now can I go see 594 maybe
or is this this is a bad idea m-maybe
this move intending light a4 yeah that's
that that's something that I like night
f4 i'll be up to six sm oh that's
embarrassing i completely forgot that
this is possible mmm not good
I just didn't pay any attention to this
move
huh
III before 95 it looks very artificial
he can maybe even play b5 that sets much
that could be just good night air for
how stupid I just should play look t2r
whatever ok at least I can make some
sense out of this maybe ok f5
no f5 give him something to a team but
not sure if it is really a something
radon just just active looking mmm take
not sure that I really want to take it
the night is looking it's looking ok on
their forward it's not threatening much
at the moment I think I still have maybe
rookie one coming
ok this this announced 92
maybe maybe no I should take that's not
very nice to play with this active
bishop on deform g3 he might even just
take i know i can i can recapture text
eggs i always have kimchi too so i can
play that asking him where his look and
tends to go g4 is also not an ideal
square 96's coming maybe can play some
tech tech based on the g3 square like
rook g3 here which entry takes Queen
takes time morning it's at least a draw
I can't go night before as well or just
go here let's just go there Queen d5
check I just have F 3 which does that
really help and much and now
now I I'm okay I'm okay I have played
rugby one rupee t-72 Sivan even okay for
me I would any big hassle
my hat's it's that's just that's just
going to be equal at the end with the
SEC tivity check yeah very comfortably
equal even better for white i will get c
6 but still it should be a draw nah
maybe not maybe not it's not bad the
seaborne check check
ah nice nice counter play for and it's
it's even a major wow that's really nice
didn't see that at all check check check
check check come on check check whatever
yeah I mean what can you do I really was
just winning around around this point so
I feel I could I could continue here the
sea porn too does win but two seconds
but yeah it was a very complicated game
which I really think around here like
look to look very much in control yeah I
really already have forgot apart bishop
before which is really silly I think
this should be about equal is a typical
position of this line and nothing that
white can be particularly happy about
just about equal and um yeah but 9 a-4
was a bad idea and really I really
didn't didn't think of Bishop Bishop
before makes a night look really silly
so I could have played f5 right away
with a good game and jam what I would be
interested in is also this position I
thought that around here should be okay
again yeah the
just confirmed by by the engine my night
is returning our queen d 1 oops quinte
one you want a strong double attack g4
and d4 I felt that this was somehow
shaky but I know quindi one nope nope
okay here I'm just equal yeah but this
end game now this end game now is
definitely tricky for black checker huge
activity founder a nice defense here
with with the with them to k.o kinetics
and now with this g5 move really
shocking i cannot take because of
checkmate because of the mate so I
needed to play this which costs lots of
time and why does in very good shape
here turnabout plus to the engine gives
but yeah it was a mess 13 against 10
seconds ok thanks for watching